the actresses who are nominated tonight
I think are characteristic of a new
actor if you will there's a part of this
town or community that we call Hollywood
that make the films in which we see the
studio system is dead
meaning no longer can those few who are
gifted enough and talented enough those
actors who don't take the first job that
comes along have a choice now they
aren't handed a number of roles four or
five within a year by the studio they
pick and their choice or the careers is
as much dependent on the roles which
they turn down and as much as the ones
they choose
so each actress tonight for the most
part probably has been a part of the
inception of the part the writing the
rewriting a part of the production of it
and the selection of the other actors
the post-production of it and even the
promotion of the film
most of these actresses nominate tonight
probably have been with this one role
for one two or three years there were
little tots when they started out
and before they get any older perhaps we
should get on with the business at hand
for her performance is a woman who used
a power she herself hardly understood to
bring healing and health to an unhappy
Midwestern town miss Ellen Burstyn for
resurrection
and for her performance is a woman who
grows from naivete to strength and
survives no less an adversary than the
United States Army miss Goldie Hawn as
Private Benjamin
her role is a mother unable and
unwilling to bend her own self-imposed
restrictions on the meaning of love and
life miss Mary Tyler Moore and ordinary
people
and for her performance as a world
hardened woman who finds unexpected
humanity within herself during a
desperate effort to save a child's life
and in so doing saves her own miss miss
Gena Rowlands in Gloria
for her patrol portrayal of a woman who
conquered ignorance and poverty to
become the synonym for the world she now
represents the [ __ ] spacek and Coal
Miner's Daughter
ladies and gentlemen of the Academy your
choice is Miss [ __ ] Spacek
from this is the greatest night but the
first time in my life I'm speechless I I
started to work on Coal Miner's Daughter
with a with a bunch of strangers and I
finished working on Coal Miner's
Daughter with a bunch of friends and I
want to thank Loretta Lynn my wonderful
director my glass head and Tommy Lee
Jones my Dolittle and Beverly D'Angelo
and Bob Larson and Shawn Daniel and
Bernie Schwartz and Michael Chen itch
and Tom Rickman and Jo Thompkins and Pam
Weis and the lady who gave me all that
hair Lorraine Robeson and my wonderful
husband Jack and all the cast and crew
that worked on Coal Miner's Daughter I
share this with you and I love you
you